kids one of the things you'll learn
about relationships is that you're never
done getting to know someone everyone
has secrets I think I could wreak on the
origin of the narration sin and say it
was inspired by How I Met Your Mother
and none of you would notice because
this show has as much narration as
Outlander has sex and well narration
also speaking of Secrets these poor
children are held captive and their dads
study just waiting to find out how their
dad met her mother you know how to make
crepes that is so cool is it though I
just googled how to make crepes and it
looks like about six basic ingredients
in 30 minutes later you have fruit
pancakes which let's be honest that's
all they are and then there was Derrick
and Counting you that was a total of oh
I got her tunnel making it Robin's 2006
sexual partner total part of the story
is weird but I'll say again he's telling
his kids this you're scared of the Seven
Dwarfs just doc he's creepy I mean the
guy went to medical school what's he
doing living with six coal miners Robert
makes a good point would be fantastic at
cinemasins I just don't feel like going
to a mall we can split a Cinnabon I'm
sorry split a Cinnabon who does that who
decides to not eat the entire cinema no
I don't go to malls sorry I just don't
like walls I know they're in New York
City but malls were still a thing in
2006 and Robin's been hanging out with
them for a year and a half at this point
at least plus Barney and Lily and
Marshalls seem to really be into balls
this would have already come up in a
better chance you have of hitting the
fatal Oh moment
extry my college girlfriend was always
on my case about the big o moment and
when I refused to find out more it was
fatal to our relationship promise ring
I made a pact with God to stay a virgin
till I'm married
Oh burdened dreaming I love you I used
to be a dude trance training they speak
French there too God that place is a
mess Canada shaming Jesus my shaming sin
skills are going to have to go up a
notch for this [ __ ] show guys there's
no way Robin is married it's ludicrous
to even suggest it Thank You Barney cuz
it's porn and
and what if Robin was an ex-porn star
does that diminish the relationship that
she currently has you could argue it
makes it more interesting okay what if I
just asked Robin point-blank if she has
a husband direct honesty in a sitcom
but however will the drama continue if
the characters go for a straight-up
honest connection oh do you think the
show has anything other than laughs for
audience reaction wouldn't this moment
have played a little better with a sort
of all because Ted is slightly
heartbroken oh yeah I still think is
good enough you order pancakes you get
waffles that's good enough
oh no it's not Ted you send that waffle
back what my girlfriend's married
keeping until Barney does oh right like
you need an excuse to watch porn
Canadian porn trust me when I tell you
they're universal health care system
doesn't cover breast implants American
health insurance doesn't cover implants
either with very few exceptions surgeons
mastectomy porn is not on the exception
list he just emailed me that it will be
up and running on myspace MySpace I'm
sorry I was a bad girl while we find out
shortly this is actually a pop music
video what are the chances it would
start off like a random pornhub video to
make Barney think he's correct I'm
guessing there's a bhoot 0% chance also
this is a music video for a 16 year old
even if it's just making a parody of
poor and this is go I want to stress
that I was young yeah you were I mean
really Barney is an absolute back I was
a teenage pop star in Canada there are
plenty of things that don't date well in
this episode for instance everything
Barney says but that doesn't take away
from the fact that this might actually
be one of the best sitcom reveals ever
weird like jtqo letters and show up when
it goes to the wine shop there's a beer
there it is however there in the earlier
scene before the commercial break when
they first see the Robin sparkles video
please PLEASE internet friends let this
be the next rickroll so why is make it
Sparkle three separate words here when
at the beginning of the video make and
it had no space between them damn for a
popular music video the editors really
hate consistent spacing also god dammit
song is stuck in my head and I'm
starting to like it
shame shame make sure you click that
Bell icon but clicking the little bell
icon is how you make sure you get
notified every time we release a video
so click it so what's the deal with you
and malls so what's the deal with brunch
I mean if it's a combination of
breakfast and lunch how come there's no
lover or no winner the better chance you
have of hitting the fatal o moment the
old moment I might be showing her my oh
face I love you don't hurt read amazed
because I used to be one that's why
Marshall and I don't keep any secrets
keep it C hard give it to her and I
begin part one of my 11-part series of
the power and mystery of the human
vagina or should I say
Robin sparkles what is your name